what else do we got here we got somebody
right here how are you not selling these
shirts Brenda
so guys Joan in Seattle lifted in my
garage
quarantine [ __ ] I know you know how
it is I got a king interesting for you
stretch joints lifted riding bikes you
know whatever ready don't see in Spokane
next month
dang buzz buzz looking like two wings
stop drumsticks broke yeah the wings
don't stop never stop extra crispy
those wings barely yield this guy first
of all there is a six-year-old who's
missing his clothes right now yup in the
shorts to the top it's too tight my man
you be thick didn't have let the whole
world know dude yeah I mean I've heard
of a shoehorn but I've never heard of a
shirt hole I can't even get into that
shirt it turns around to look like
Beyonce put on some jeans I love the
idea George snow I love George I want to
get some how you can be for jorts but
against [ __ ] fanny packs we go
together do not there you ain't a butter
and jelly I'm not one step at a time
dude yeah step in there shallow end
let's both get some George yeah they
make all the sense well they don't have
to be that tight though why don't we
have King in this thing George and on
the pocket says buzz-buzz Gang Gang do a
lot of prison sex what do they think
about jorts and stuff like that in
Ireland do they have no how's the
fashion house the fashion Island we like
scarves and stuff we don't like Jarts
yeah yeah scarfs a lot of hats but not
like a lot of like Paperboy yeah yeah
our peak oil jackets yeah we all dress
the exact same you have to wear like
black shoes getting into a pub or a club
sometimes if you forget black shoes you
your friend gives you black socks and
you put them hand over your white shoes
pretty cool this guy needs my advice for
him just go one size up and everything
so feel like I think I wear medium get
the large dude but also double X you
know you don't wear medium yeah yeah the
George so I think are kind of alright
looking on the edges summer is coming
dude let's do it some you have no pair
of jeans we bake our own George do bring
some of your [ __ ] old jeans around if
brendan has to have a lot of jars okay I
celebrate the guys out
sun's out thighs I mean I'm willing to
put my legs out I just don't want to I
don't get that you have that peach
popping out the back dude doesn't for
you the other day he goes he said I'm
gonna get you and Keith Peterson to
fight at 165
oh the ref with the ref it looks just
like Nick Swardson who basically there's
no doubt that Nick Swardson will play
Keith Peterson a biopic of these guys
I'd rather see you and Keith piece yeah
what is he you and Keith Peterson
[ __ ] fight Nick Swardson
yeah if Nick's my I don't want my rough
jug I don't want my life in his hands be
as a neck tattoo it's a bad idea I think
you do not rather see you and keep you
in a spelling bee than a fight and
sometimes why baby let's see if they got
Nick Swardson in there
yeah Nick definitely looks like him a
little bit enough huh yeah that picture
right there to the right and left of
that one yeah or actually one you were
chosen is good you look so he looks a
little like if I can see it yes imagine
Nick was your ring for a real fight ring
and the ref was just so [ __ ] too far
does that ever I did that ever happen
where you would get in sometimes you
would look at the wreck the roster
always had like Big John or I had Herb
Dean or you know because when they're
heavyweights they usually have the good
rafts there but like Dominick Cruz said
when that Keith dude came in the back he
was like can is there I can veto this
yeah the [ __ ] neck tattoo yeah no way
like alcohol and cigarette now am i
saying he's on a con cigarettes no those
are dumb at Cruz's worth yeah I don't I
don't know he fishing you deliver a
chucky cheese pizza in here right now
yeah but you're loving Dominick Cruz is
I do can I get a different Ref for the
commissioners like now is who you were
side man
Keith Peterson's a legend man I think
he's my favorite rat I think you're
loose on the term legend really duties
no-nonsense man nobody else had is that
you've never seen her being is he not
I've seen Big John the best of the best
yeah confusion just a guy those other
guys are like they've been do it forever
he learned from them I would imagine
yeah
easy on the term legend though you know
all right well what was the last we got
to do was the last one we just did it
was jorts I'm all for George Smith do do
we gonna start the movement now the
summer's finally hit and let the jorts
hit you cheeks out dude
they're always out no they're not man
you're horrible hide them I keep getting
charts ads on Instagram and it's Vic I'm
like how was my life what have I done
wrong get those whitey legs out get some
Whitey Bulger let's now for us dude you
got your pants John Stockton doubt for
the fam gone Stockton had some gams on a
hit Wow um would if you see a man's leg
and it got short shorts on cat how does
that resonate with you is that uh depend
on the leg I think it really depends on
the confidence the legs do make a
difference to like that guy was just
rockin he didn't care that it was too
tight on him but his legs were juicy so
I was not bad exactly if you got it
flaunt it yeah he had huge legs he has a
freaking those wet markets yeah you know
oh yeah I'm a boy looked like a squatter
[ __ ]
chucky cheese right now dude I'm tell
you I got these with Marcus oh yeah
we're going to hell man no we're not
yeah we are Brendan stop watching most
of the episodes one time I was alright I
was at a Irish hospital and I was
getting like an STD check and they had
me like my pants down penis out the
whole shebang
and I Narses like you mind if I bring in
some training students she brought it
like four women
I was texting one of them oh wow I was
like oh hi and I just naked from the
waist down but she knew ice it was like
tiny saw that helps make the call there
what are the odds of that but ever since
my legs have been hidden away with real
white legs always hi yeah that's like to
you on the guess that's like me can you
tan or no oh yeah I'll have a good tan I
just come be part I find that hard to
believe
no no I'm beautiful by the time oh yeah
that's stunning
[Music]
nothing
[Music]